madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de
ce jeudi 22 juillet marquée par la
publication du rapport sur les attentats
du 11 septembre qui pointe les carences
du système de sécurité
preuve par l'image cette vidéo montrant
avec quelle facilité les pirates de
l'air ont pu franchir les contrôles à
l'aéroport de washington
les grosses cylindrées en sursis dans
son plan climat le ministre de
l'ecologie maintient le principe du
bonus malus sur les véhicules les plus
polluants
mais sa mise en application dépendra
d'un vote au parlement en septembre
dix millions de français ne partiront
pas en vacances cette année et pourtant
70% des bons vacances offertes par les
caisses d'allocations familiales ne sont
pas utilisés dans ce journal vous verrez
un document exceptionnel qui nous montre
un autre visage de dubaï ce riche état
du golfe exploitent chaque année des
centaines de travailleurs étrangers
vivent dans des conditions déplorables
une fois de plus lance armstrong a
dominé le tour de france en remportant
la dernière étape des alpes mais vous le
verrez l'américain ne bénéficie pas
d'une popularité à la hauteur de ses
exploits on a appris en fin d'après midi
la mort de sacha distel il est décédé
des suites d'une longue maladie à l'âge
de 71 ans sacha distel a marqué la
chanson française depuis les années 60
un parcours jalonné de succès et claude
crespo
oh
sans amour sans soucis sans problème
label'vie en 64 cette chanson a fait le
tour du monde
sacha distel devient le chanteur de
charme
le crooner français
oui
l'appel
ce fou de jazz qui ai eu la chance
d'avoir comme prof de guitare henri
salvador voulait chanter ses idoles
django reinhardt et lionel hampton
moi je me considère comme un comme un
noir américain
parce qu'en fait en fait je suis né
vraiment ddd dès l'âge de 13 14 ans 15
ans au moment où j'ai touché une guitare
pour la première fois mais ayant fait
six en piano classique déjà je me suis
considéré tout de suite comme comme
quelqu'un qui est qu'ils ressentaient le
blues la musique de jazz
quel la pluie tombée sur moi oui mais
moi j'ai près comme si je ne la sens des
bap jeunes ne bronche pas car j'aime
voilà
ya le bon temps
un sourire éclatant un oeil de velours
est un parfait bilinguisme avec accent
en font dans les années 80 la coqueluche
des anglais un seul regret n'avoir pas
pu monter une comédie musicale autour de
l'homme aux canotiers maurice chevalier
mais un ruban sert au chapeau parce que
ça fait plus sacha distel a dû à la
belle vie à 71 ans à l'épée sacrée mais
les hommages se multiplient line renaud
faisait partie du cercle intime de sacha
distel beaucoup d'émotion line renaud
vient juste d'apprendre la disparition
de son ami on les écoute vous me l'avez
appris au bureau et je ne savais pas
demain que je suis encore sous le choc
est à la fois pas surpris parce que j'ai
déjeuné avec lui un mois m'avait demandé
en italie déjeuner tous les deux et je
l'avais trouvé toujours quand elle est
arrivée dans un restaurant toujours
cette cette allure de jeune homme ne
savait pas que je mens
superbe et quand tout au cours du
déjeuner
percevez je savais que ça chantait mal
je me battais on n'a pas parlé qu'à la
mairie mais dans son regard
lol était loin l'oeil était triste et le
il est beaucoup mieux si j'ai même pas
un an il
il m'a fait la surprise il était sur
scène au petit journal qui à un moment
il est allé chercher quelque chose je
pensais que c'était une partition de
mussy et il m'a offert la photo de ses
13 ans lui à côté de moi sur la plage
avec c'est cette image là et se sourit
je l'avais déjà te sourire ce charme
pour moi c'est quelqu'un de très très
très très cher à mon coeur chez famille
avec cette famille voilà l'actualité
c'est aussi la vidéo diffusée depuis
hier soir sur les chaînes américaines
qui est la preuve par l'image des
carences du système de sécurité dénoncés
par le rapport sur les attentats du 11
septembre
les images montrent avec quelle facilité
les cinq pirates de l'air ont pu ainsi
passer les portiques de contrôle à
l'aéroport de washington
les images décrypté par notre
correspondant alain de chalvron 11
septembre 2001 7 heures du matin à
l'aéroport de dulles près de washington
les caméras de surveillance enregistre
le passage des pirates de l'air qui vont
deux heures plus tard projeté un avion
d'american airlines sur le pentagone
le premier pirate passe le détecteur de
métaux comme une lettre à la poste
rien ne sonne le deuxième déclenché les
alarmes se fait contrôler manuellement
puis va récupérer son bagage
imperturbablement même chose pour le
troisième
nawaf al hazmi ils passent aussi sans
problème le contrôle manuel mais
regardez bien l'homme à la chemise
blanche et son frère salem
il évite lui carrément le portique la
manoeuvre et l repérer ou bien son sac
et il suspect toujours est il que les
deux frères font l'objet d'un contrôle
renforcé le sac de nawaf va même passer
au détecteur d'explosifs en revanche le
cutter qui va servir aux détournements
passe à l'ast à aucun moment non plus on
ne consultera la liste des terroristes
recherchés
dommage l'un des deux frères étaient
dessus le cinquième pirates le pilote
s'en tire avec une simple fouille on est
frappé en tout cas par le calme et la
tenue soignée de ces hommes qui vont
mourir et tu est stupéfait aussi par la
facilité avec laquelle ils ont opéré
c'est un des multiples
dysfonctionnements épinglés par le
rapport parlementaire publié
et aujourd'hui autre exemple zacarias
moussaoui le français arrêté un mois
avant les attentats
parce que dans son école de pilotage il
ne s'intéresser qu'au virage et bien peu
au décollage et à l'atterrissage
le rapport alarmiste de l'agent local du
fbi n'est jamais arrivée au sommet de la
hiérarchie
en réalité les rapporteurs estiment
surtout que les deux administrations
bush et clinton avait très largement
sous-estimé le danger que représentait
oussama ben laden il y avait donc un
manque de vigilance à tous les niveaux
de l'état
ce sera finalement député de dire s'ils
acceptent ou non d'appliquer un bonus
malus pénalisons l'achat des véhicules
les plus polluants dans son plan climat
le ministre de l'ecologie repousse donc
à septembre la décision
les verts accuse déjà le gouvernement de
recul et de mensonges l'ukba 10,1 sophie
métal mouchoirs blancs ou mouchoirs noir
pour l'instant rien ne change en termes
de taxes finalement propre ou sale à la
sortie du pot d'échappement les voitures
neuves ne seront pas fiscalement
pénaliser tout au moins dans l'immédiat
même au point mort donc l'idée du bonus
malus continue de séduire le ministre de
l'environnement qu'il promet de
soumettre l'idée au parlement à
l'automne
le bonus malus c'est avant tout une
prime incitative pour permettre aux
français d'acheter des voitures propres
et des voitures moins polluantes
meilleur mais pour son éventuelle
application il faut aussi attendre le
feu vert de bruxelles
autant dire que ce n'est pas pour tout
de suite voyez aujourd'hui nous
attendons donc le ministre nous dire le
bonus malus n'est pas dégagé en touche
du plan climat
mais il sera juste soumis à l'arbitrage
du parlement c'est comme une façon de
repousser à nouveau les échéances pour
acheter ce puissant v8 le nouveau
processeur aurait dû s'acquitter d'une
taxe de 3200 euros une mesure jugée
discriminatoire à l'égard des voitures
allemandes plus puissante que les
françaises le chancelier gerhard
schröder lui même avait évoqué un péril
pour la construction européenne certains
et mettant même des doutes quant à
l'honnêteté des limites de pollution
fixée alors c'était discriminant parce
que un hasard certains fait que les
voitures françaises n'étaient pas
atteints par le mali
alors que plus de 50% des voitures
allemandes étaient atteintes par ce
malus là le trait a été très bien tiré
il faut se mettre dans un contexte
égalitaire à chacun de pouvoir toutes
les marques de travailler ensemble de se
mettre d'accord sur une règle
le bonus malus continue donc sa route et
soulignent la difficulté de déterminer
le plus polluant dans une telle masse de
véhicules
à chaque jour sa nouvelle brèche dans
les 35 heures après bosch à vénissieux
après celles dans les vosges de plus en
plus de sociétés semblent vouloir
imposer une hausse du temps de travail
les entreprises sont-elles en train de
s'aventurer sur la pente glissante
évoqué par jacques chirac le 14 juillet
éléments de réponse avec nathalie moisan
benoît gallerey travailler plus sans
gagner plus c'est ce que viennent
d'accepter les cadres de cette pme lors
d'un référendum organisé par la
direction danoise de l'entreprise les
techniciens ont aussi accepté de perdre
des jours de rtt contre une augmentation
de salaire les ouvriers eux ont refusé
22 jours d accepter c'est quelque chose
qui est lourd administrés et c'est
quelque chose qui coûte cher pour
l'entreprise un référendum contesté par
la cfdt selon elle les salariés
n'avaient pas le choix il n'y a pas de
doute un essai c'est du chantage à
l'emploi parce que on vous dit outré
plus à être numérisés signé à des
licenciements
je veux pas je vois pas ce qu'on peut
appeler ça autrement autre exemple chez
le fabricant d'électroménager seb
la direction souhaite relever le temps
de travail de ses usines vosgienne de 32
à 35 heures
pourtant la durée légale du travail et y
restera 35 heures le président de la
république l'a rappelé le 14 juillet
mais sur le terrain depuis l'accord
signé chez bosch
il en va autrement au grand dam des
socialistes ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est de demander aux salariés de
travailler plus en gagnant - et cela si
le gouvernement qui en a ouvert la
brèche par le discours idéologique de
sarkozy qui a joué avec le feu sur les
35 heures par le projet que prépare
actuellement gouvernement de ne pas
payer les heures supplémentaires depuis
les assouplissements déjà voté et la loi
fillon 22 branches professionnelles ont
déjà conclu des accords pour augmenter
le temps de travail par des heures
supplémentaires mieux payés c'est le cas
du bâtiment de la coiffure ou de
l'épicerie mais certains députés dans la
majorité veulent plus il faut sortir de
tout cela est donc une disposition
législative dès la rentrée pour
permettre à la négociation de s'engager
dans toutes les entreprises ou à défaut
dans toutes les branches dans les
entreprises la brèche est donc ouverte
la remise en cause des 35 heures promet
d'être la principale pomme de discorde
entre la majorité et l'opposition à la
rentrée à noter que les députés ont
définitivement adopté la réforme du
statut d'edf gdf le parti socialiste a
voté contre le texte
la france est en vacances mais pas
toutes la france 10 millions de nos
concitoyens ne partiront pas cette année
souvent pour des raisons économiques
et pourtant fait étonnant deux tiers des
bons vacances distribuées par les
caisses d'allocations familiales ne sont
pas utilisés julia delage claude-marc
profiter enfin du temps qui passe grâce
aux bons vacances des caisses
d'allocations familiales c'est un luxe
que s'offre chaque année près de 500
mille familles
donc ce centre de vacances au coeur de
la vienne 5 à 10 familles par semaine
finance grâce à ces aides
une partie de leurs vacances n'offrent
bien alléchante
apparemment vous avez une aide en fait à
l'enfant donc vous allez une prise en
charge par enfant et par jour elle avec
une par une par parental quand les
parents sont avec les enfants qui permet
de réduire le coût du séjour
de 25 à même voire 70% beaucoup mais
très insuffisant pour la majorité des
familles à faible revenu pour bénéficier
des bons vacances rebaptisé aides aux
temps libres deux conditions avoir perçu
au moins une prestation familiale dans
l'année et avoir un quotient familial
inférieur à 500 euros exemple un ménage
classique 2 adultes + 2 enfants vivant
avec 1500 euros par mois possède un
quotient familial de 500 euros limite
mais suffisant pour bénéficier des bons
vacances mais pour certaines familles
plafond des quotas n'efface pas les
habitudes les personnes qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de partir en vacances peuvent
avoir peur de partir en vacances aussi
bizarre que ça paraisse dans la mesure
où elles vont se dire qu'elles ne
connaissent pas les codes qu'elle ne
savent pas vont être craintif comment
s'habiller comment se comportaient etc
peur de l'inconnu problèmes de
financement en tout 70 % des bons
vacances ne sont pas utilisés par les
familles qui les reçoivent
l'enjeu est donc d'importance chaque
année près d'un français sur trois ne
part pas en vacances et pour ceux qui
sont restés au nord de la france eux
prudents météo france émet une carte de
vigilance orange
des orages forts pourraient éclater ce
soir en normandie dans le centre et en
ile de france
ils remonteront progressivement vers la
région nord puis s'atténueront dans la
nuit deux orages qui se sont déjà
abattues hier soir dont plusieurs
départements florence bukiya l'auvergne
durement souffert des orages d'hier dans
l'allier une jeune scout de 14 ans qu'on
paie avec dix-sept jeunes et leurs
accompagnateurs
la foudre est tombée sur sa tante
l'adolescente est décédée avant
l'arrivée des secours
plus au sud dans le cantal pas de
victime mais des dégâts sur le réseau
ferroviaire
des dizaines d'arbres encombrent les
voies près de l'art au bout dans le sud
ouest
cette fois ce sont des grêlons gros
comme des balles de tennis qui ont
surpris tout le monde les avait ramassé
quand en moins d'une heure plus de 600
toitures ont été endommagées ou en
partie arraché les pompiers débordés ont
demandé des renforts des départements
voisins
l'an dernier à la même époque un gros
orage était déjà passé par là mais ils
étaient moins violent les pompiers s'est
vu remettre des bandes de scotch sur le
toit et ça suffisait l'année scolaire
dans le tour hs complètement les
belgique pour 6 d'autres départements
français ont aussi souffert de ces
orages en meurthe et moselle un camping
a été évacué juste-à-temps chutes
d'arbres ruptures de câbles edf à haute
tension un périmètre de sécurité a dû
être installé deux adolescents ont été
mises en examen dans le meurtre du jeune
steve retrouvé assassiné dimanche soir
dans un fossé à une plage près de calais
il s'agit de deux amis de la victime
les adolescentes avoué le meurtre les
jeunes gens se seraient disputés à
l'issue d'une soirée trop arrosée
et puis nouvelle libération aujourd'hui
dans l' affaire d'outreau la justice a
ordonné la sortie de prison de franck
lavier condamné à six ans de détention
avant-hier c'est et l'abbé denis viel
qui avait été remise en liberté en
attendant son procès en appel
et puis maxime brunerie comparaîtra
devant une cour d'assises pour la
tentative d'assassinât de jacques chirac
le 14 juillet 2002 le procès devrait se
tenir à la fin de l'année prochaine
comme chaque soir cette semaine nous
revenons sur une affaire qui pour
l'instant n'a pas été élucidé cette fois
nous reparlons d'un triple assassinat
dans la somme c'était durant l'année
2002 aujourd'hui seule une enquête a
abouti aurélia guima carole grieco
christelle aurait dû fêter ses 20 ans
dans quelques jours
cet été ce sera aussi l'anniversaire de
sa mort déjà deux ans d'absence et de
questions
ne peuvent pas famille de l'avoir devant
un mot que la version d'iphoto châtelain
non c'est beaucoup plus qu'avant c'était
le 21 août 2002 à villers bretonneux
christelle dubuisson été retrouvée
égorgée sous ce fourgon devenu depuis
une pièce maîtresse de l'enquète traces
de cheveux de sang jusqu'aux fibres des
vêtements de la victime tout a été
expertisé au total 1600 analyse depuis
deux ans un travail de fourmi qui n'a
pas encore mené aux coupables mais les
enquêteurs ne désespèrent pas nous avons
la conviction que le tueur a été obligé
de laisser des traces de son passage
mais pour l'instant aucun élément
permettant de confondre celui qui fait
encore aujourd'hui figure de suspect
numéro un rien à voir
pour jean paul leconte violeur
récidiviste déjà arrêté grâce à son adn
c'était en novembre 2002 après le
meurtre de patricia leclerc près de
péronne un meurtre commis moins de deux
mois avant celui de christelle dubuisson
et les similitudes ne s'arrêtent pas là
proximité des lieux
il connaît bien la région proximité
aussi dans la barbarie des crimes et
j'ajouterais que depuis l'interpellation
de le compter son arrestation
y'a plus crime autre certitude des
enquêteurs à la même époque dans le même
secteur plusieurs autres tueurs ont sévi
jean paul leconte était en prison quand
elodie kulik a été tué par au moins
trois individus leurs voix ont été
enregistrés sur la ligne téléphonique
des pompiers alors qu'il le dit appeler
au secours
trois voix n'est toujours pas de nom je
promets je trouverais on les trouvera je
ne doute pas qu'on les trouvera encore
chaud je ne trouverai pas je fais
confiance à ce niveau là où l'enquêteur
fait leur travail
le chèque au fait ils font deux ans et
demi après le meurtre d'elodie dix
enquêteurs travaillent toujours à plein
temps sur cette affaire en vain pour
l'instant
ce soir nous avons choisi de vous
présenter un document exceptionnel qui
nous montre une autre facette de dubaï
l'un des plus riche état du golfe
chaque année le pays recrute une main
d'oeuvre bon marché
et en inde au bangladesh et au népal les
centaines d'hommes qui vivent dans des
conditions déplorables coupés de leurs
familles coupé du monde
une forme d'esclavagé moderne samah
soula francis deniau koné à première vue
on pourrait croire que ce sont des
prisonniers
mais si ces sommes sont captifs ce n'est
que de leur misère
ils viennent d'inde du pakistan du
bangladesh où on est allé les chercher
pour en faire les bâtisseurs de dubaï en
route pour les chantiers ramassage
organisé par les employeurs des bus
bondés des ventilateurs à bout de
souffle il fait 45 degrés trop content
d'obtenir un visa pour le pays de l'or
noir
aucun ne pense bien sûr à négocier les
conditions de travail et encore moins le
salaire
je ne savais pas combien j'allais gagner
mais quand j'ai reçu ma première paye
j'étais très déçu c'est un salaire très
bas
120 dollars par mois 50 heures de
travail par semaine dans la chaleur et
la poussière
sans compter les accidents ces hommes
construisent des villas qui seront
vendus des centaines de milliers de
dollars à leur arrivée tous ont dû
remettre leur passeport à leur employeur
un moyen de pression absolue sur une
main d'oeuvre sans défense mais
officiellement cette confiscation est
uniquement administratives
on dit toujours aux entrepreneurs vous
n'avez pas le droit de garder les
passeports comme moyen de chantage ou de
pression
vous ne gardez les passeports que pour
des raisons administratives et au loin
de dubaï de ses grandeurs et ses dorures
à l'abri des regards
voici où sont parqués les travailleurs
douche à l'extérieur confort spartiate
ce centre est pourtant loin d'être le
pire les ouvriers nous indique un autre
centre d'hébergement où les conditions
sont déplorables mais impossible de le
filmer
si je voulais centrer je perds mon
travail d'ailleurs s'appeler je pense
que vous comprenez ici chacun envoie
chaque mois 80 % de son salaire à sa
famille certains restent des années mais
aucun regroupement familial n'est
possible on sait qu'on est juste là pour
gagner un peu d'argent ramenée des
devises et rentrer chez nous pas
question de s'installer scheer quand
cela repart quiero d'autres les
remplaceront
l'infernal cycle de la pauvreté
la lutte contre le cancer vous le savez
c'est un des grands chantiers de jacques
chirac le chef de l'état s'est rendu ce
matin dans un centre à la pointe de la
recherche
il s'agit du centre de protonthérapie de
l'institut curie or c'est alors la
protonthérapie c'est une technique très
innovante de radiothérapie qui permet de
mieux cibler les tumeurs depuis 13 ans
3000 patients français ont déjà pu
bénéficier de cette technique sophie
rodier n'est dit mme picard 3e séance de
soins pour ce patient un traitement de
haute précision
la protonthérapie pour détruire une
tumeur cancéreuse quasiment inaccessible
niché derrière son oeil gauche
un dispositif impressionnant l'oeil doit
être maintenue grands ouverts et le
patient parfaitement immobilisé pour que
le rayon de protons atteignent 16 cible
on a mis les gouttes au niveau de la de
la cornée non ça juste endormi de
superficie d'accord de lui il a pas mal
non la séance peut commencer
la tumeur va être bombardé de profonds
pendant soixante et une seconde fille
c'est le point monsieur l'intérêt des
protons q2 et leur grande précision
il vise au millimètre près la tumeur
sans abîmer les tissus sains al'inverse
de la radiothérapie classique - ciblées
qui risque de détruire le nerf optique
on voit une petite lueur bleue quand les
bretons semblent arriver sinon il n'y a
aucune douleur soit rien du tout
aujourd'hui la protonthérapie concerne
essentiellement les adultes
l'avenir c'est de soigner les très
jeunes enfants les enfants sont en
pleine croissance
donc leurs tissus sont fragiles surtout
aux radiations
si vous les irradiés peu de cerveau chez
un enfant dans l'avenir il aura
certainement moins de problèmes des
fonctions supérieures par exemple des
problèmes de croissance osseuse
il n'existe que deux centres de
protonthérapie en france
cette technique est uniquement réservée
pour l'instant à certains cancers du
cerveau et de lait les producteurs de
fruits et légumes ont multiplié les
actions ces dernières semaines depuis le
mois de mai tomates melons et aubergines
se négocie en dessous de leur prix de
revient conséquence les maraîchers
travaille à perte depuis trois mois
exemples concrets près de perpignan paul
de genève vincent ferrer les salades
c'était déjà très mal vendu durant
l'hiver et aujourd'hui avec les tomates
ce n'est guère mieux lucien guitare et
maraîcher à perpignan sous cette serre
d'un peu moins d'un hectare et demi il
produit 1000 tonnes de tomates chaque
année il sait déjà qu'il vendra toute sa
production mais en perdant de l'argent
aujourd'hui les cours de deux marchés
sont de 0 040 60 centimes d'euros dont
départ départ des départs de mon
exploitation
alors comment coûts de production se
situe à 0 87
l'ensemble de la filière maraîchère du
bassin méditerranéen subit depuis
quelques mois cette crise les
explications sont diverses
d'abord la concurrence étrangère venue
de l'espagne voisine où des pays de
l'est
une concurrence avec laquelle les
distributeurs sauf parfaitement joué on
a depuis un mois malgré tous les appels
du pied qu'on a fait on n'a pas réussi à
mobiliser un petit peu pour que essayer
de faire remonter les prix on n'y arrive
pas et pourtant la grande distribution
d'y faire un effort dans la région en ne
vendant que des produits locaux dans ses
supermarchés
lucien guitare lui vend tout c'est au
match et cet expéditeur
le directeur se dit très inquiet pour la
filière
or la limite des produits blancs au mois
de juin pourtant un accord a été signé
sous l'autorité du ministre de
l'économie et des finances pour tenter
de rééquilibrer le rapport de force
entre distributeurs et producteurs
demain le secrétaire d'état à
l'agriculture viendra ici
il écoutera de nouveau les maraîchers
mais aura sans doute bien du mal à les
rassurer
autre mouvement de colère celui des
éleveurs de moutons aujourd'hui à gap
ils étaient 300 à défiler avec leurs
troupes pour protester contre la
présence de loups dans les alpages
visiblement ils ne sont pas rassurés par
le plan d'action annoncé lundi par le
ministre de l'écologie serge lepeltier à
autoriser les préfets des alpes à
organiser l'abattage de quatre loups
cette année en cas d' attaques répétées
et puis une aide de 60 millions d'euros
sera versé d'ici 2006 aux producteurs de
lait c'est la réponse d'hervé gaymard
aux nombreuses manifestations du
printemps dernier hier soir le ministre
de l'agriculture a également fait des
propositions pour tenter de sortir la
viticulture française de la crise alors
parmi les mesures phares la possibilité
d'utiliser des copeaux de bois pour
améliorer le produit et séduire les
consommateurs
une méthode jusqu'ici interdite en
france mais déjà répandu dans les pays
du nouveau monde david bizier bernard
bonne arme pratique jusque là interdite
en france où seul le fût de chêne est
autorisé des copeaux de bois que l'on
fait infuser dans le vin moyen rapide et
peu chères de donner un goût boisé qui
plaît aux consommateurs sur les marchés
internationaux en aquitaine où l'on veut
créer un vin de pays d'entrée de gamme
l'idée intéresse en voyage avec des
copeaux nous rendrait service pour
attaquer les marchés alain cros marchés
internationaux puisque on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la majorité des grands
marchés internationaux sont sont
attaquées sont démarrés par ce type de
produits qui arrivent d'autres régions
du monde n'y a plus que la france et
l'italie qui ne sont pas dans ce schéma
de production
certains vins étrangers vendus en france
sont boisés avec des copeaux aucune
étiquette ne le mentionnent il ya
pourtant une vraie différentes mosquées
de copeaux recenseur ou très très boisé
très très planches dans le nord
dans la bouche qui a tendance à assécher
la bouche qui n'est pas toujours très
agréables
alors que un vieillissement en fûts de
chêne
on arrive à trouver de la complexité on
arrive à trouver des arômes vanille est
beaucoup plus intéressant ce vigneron
bordelais a beaucoup de stocks
d'invendus mais pour lui pas question
d'abandonner l'appellation d'origine
contrôlée en maintenant lundi à bordeaux
22 qualité que de la barrique que les
manipulations strictement et
rigoureusement contrôlées et du jour au
lendemain on obtient tout comme ça d'un
coup de baguette magique mais la qualité
est une méthode coûteuse c'est bon petit
bordeaux de producteurs pourraient subir
la loi des vins bon marché boisé aux
copeaux des scientifiques américains ont
découvert un morceau de météorites venue
de mars la roche a été retrouvé dans
l'antarctique à 750 km du pôle sud
nicolas chateauneuf daniel lévy on en
compte tout juste une trentaine dans le
monde
et voici la petite dernière une
météorite martienne de 700 grammes
découverte en antarctique
chaque année dans cette région des
dizaines d' équipes se lancent à la
recherche des précieux minéraux leur but
décelée dans les roches martiennes des
traces de vie fossiles
un objectif partagé à des millions de
kilomètres de là sur la planète rouge
par de petits robots américains en six
mois spirit et opportunity ont déjà
largement dépassé leur durée de vie
initialement prévu après avoir trouvé de
très anciennes traces d'eau liquide à la
surface martienne opportunity se trouve
aujourd'hui dans ce cratère baptisé
endurance et qui intéresse
particulièrement les scientifiques
à l'autre bout de la planète spirit lui
a eu moins de chance
sa roue avant droite visible sur cette
dernière photo donne des signes de
fatigue mais pour les deux robots le
principal danger vient de l'arrivée dans
ces paysages déserts de l'hiver martial
températures pouvant descendre à -5
degrés la nuit
on est comme on a peu d'énergie pour
réchauffer la nuit le système le rover
lui-même il se peut que des composants
ne résiste pas cette basse température
et etc à ce que ce soit mécaniquement ou
voir une électronique qui ne fonctionne
plus l'objectif actuel de spirit est
d'atteindre cette colline mais avec
l'arrivée d'hiver les ingénieurs de la
nasa vont peut être devoir plonger le
robot en hibernation en espérant qu'il
pourra se réveiller au début de l'année
prochaine
à la veille d'un nouveau week-end classé
rouge par bison fûté une étude tord le
cou aux idées reçues les femmes
conduisent mieux que les hommes elles
sont plus prudents plus responsable et
plus respectueuse des autres conducteurs
françois jullien pieds noirs je suis via
de l'âge le type qui s'arrêtent en plein
milieu là par exemple donc ça freine au
foie
quand une femme prend le volant les
préjugés sont souvent cinglant et
pourtant ces lignes conduit depuis 20
ans et pas d'accident grave à son actif
elle est prudents mais dans l'esprit
collectif enfin surtout celui des hommes
les femmes conduisent moins bien qu'elle
eut éconduit mal en tout cas
des réflexes quillan sont pas les miens
justement eux
moi j'aime piéger par contre
en voiture avec les alors tourner moins
d'accidents quoi en effet les femmes ont
plus d'accidents en ville la plupart du
temps mais ils sont beaucoup moins grave
que les hommes les conductrices ont
trois fois moins de risques d'être tué
que les conducteurs les femmes sont donc
plus prudente c'est la conclusion de la
thèse en psychologie de ce gendarme
on observe que la femme un comportement
plus responsable au volant à savoir elle
transfère toutes ces notions de sécurité
qu'elles pratiquent habituellement avec
l'objet voiture et selon notre gendarme
psychologue c'est à partir de 42 ans
qu'un conducteur ou une conductrice
atteint l'âge de la sagesse au volant
avant le conducteur construit son
expérience avec la route
mais même à 42 ans les cadres conduisent
moins bien que les ouvriers et les
employés
le jeune cadre dynamique mène sa voiture
comme ses affaires son véhicule comme un
bureau mobile celui qui est arrivé qui a
une bonne situation qui a une grosse
voiture
il aimait moi avec ma voiture mercedes
je ne suis pas dangereux à 150 ch et ou
moins dangereux que celui qu'a une deux
chevaux à 90 km/heure
une chose est certaine au dessus de 200
km heure 100% des contrevenants sont des
hommes décidément l'ensam 5 semble
infaillible dans ce tour de france il a
confirmé sa suprématie en remportant
l'étape d'aujourd'hui la dernière dans
les alpes et puis bonne nouvelle pour
richard virenque il a conforté son
maillot à pois et devrait remporter le
trophée du meilleur grimpeur pour la
septième fois
c'est un record julien bomans laurence
iran richard virenque à l'attack
objectif gravir les sommets du jour le
mieux placé possible pour conforter son
maillot à pois virenque et aux avant
postes avec morrow et simoni haut du col
de la madeleine
il passe en deuxième position le voilà
maintenant largement en tête au
classement du meilleur grimpeur
mission accomplie richard virenque
devrait sauf accident conserver ce
maillot de meilleur grimpeur jusqu'à
paris
ce serait le septième de sa carrière une
victoire historique promet ya 10 ans
recueille année dans un acquis qu'on
passe en carrière et moi ça fait vous en
tout 14 ans acquiesce en vélo
le plaisir c'est ça sans doute l'étape
la plus dure de sauter de france
au menu chaleur et col hors catégorie
mais armstrong n'a pas l'air de souffrir
dans les derniers kilomètres seul indice
basso claudette et ulrich arrive encore
à le suivre
l'allemand tente même de discuter mais
l'art américain en a décidé autrement
canclaux des non-blancs s'échappe
armstrong n'est pas en danger et
pourtant il se défend il remporte sa
quatrième victoire individuelle dans ce
tour de france
je me sens fort j'ai bien récupéré et
puis quoi c'est le tour de france et
comme je disais bernard hinault seul
podium c'est pas de cadeaux repas avec
adobe cette victoire permet à lance
amstrong d'accroître un peu plus son
avance
il a maintenant quatre minutes 09 sur
ivan basso
lance amstrong invincible sur les routes
du tour mais mal aimés d'une partie du
public l'américain vous l'avez vu encore
hier soir à l'alpe d'huez et souvent
sifflé au bord du parcours
nathanaël de rincquesen et silva de bain
ou tenter de comprendre les raisons de
ce désamour
rien de tel qu'un bon bain de foule
parmi ses supporteurs pour se refaire
une santé
ce matin ils étaient nombreux à attendre
le maillot jaune
pourtant sur le tour armstrong n'a pas
que des amis il s'en est rendu compte
ces derniers jours ses exploits ont été
accueillis temps par des
applaudissements que par des sifflets je
suis populaire en france
il ya beaucoup de supporters sur la
route
parfois les gens disent des choses
bizarres mais c'est plus contre le
cyclisme que contre moi pourtant le
message est clair et c'est bien à lui
qu'il est adressée dopage domination la
rumeur colle à la route et si armstrong
n'était que le bouc émissaire de cette
mauvaise image qui colle au peloton
parmi les coureurs personne ne l'en vie
et crachats des insultes par rapport à
ça c'est pas justifié sais pas mais en
tout cas ces gens là c'est pourtant
désormais une tradition
armstrong l'américain est attendu par
les pseudos supporters de ses rivaux une
bêtise digne des hooligans de football
il a montré qu'il était un grand
champion mais je n'aime pas le
personnage je ne veux pas qu'ils gagnent
ce tour en 1975 merckx en route pour une
sixième victoire avait été frappé par un
supporter agacé par la domination du
belge heureusement la réussite de
l'américain ne lui attire pas de tels
problèmes
mais armstrong énerve les gars je
passais d'émotion pour être populaire
pour être aimé les jambes
seule certitude amstrong ne laisse
personne indifférent et dimanche avec ou
sans l'amour du public
il va rentrer dans l'histoire du tour
et puis on a appris aujourd'hui qu'à un
spectateur a trouvé la mort hier sur les
pentes de l'alpe d'huez après une chute
d'une quarantaine de mètres
pour ceux qui passent encore la journée
au bureau avec la climatisation nos
correspondants dans le sud vous offre
une petite carte postale plein de soleil
et de douceur de vivre estivale francis
mazoyer benoît jour dans environ 30
degrés une légère brise de mer
la calanque vite au ralenti grâce aux
annonces de dd restaurateur marseillais
les baigneurs sont vite dans l'ambiance
placés devant un cruel dilemme
cuire au soleil ou se mettre à l'ombre
d'un cabanon
il faut un peu de 10,6 de frais que vous
mettez à l'intérieur s'il fait très
chaud vous en mettez beaucoup la somme
vous vous couchez avec la chaleur il ya
ceux qui perdent l'appétit et se
contente d'un simple fruit
tout est bon pour s'apprécier ah oui
surtout la pastèque lamizana glace et
donc qu'elle est vraiment une fraîcheur
les france n2 pizza toute chaude à deux
roues sont arrivés
pour d'autres le bas est synonyme de
petit creux dès qu'il fait beau les
terrasses se remplissent à nouveau et
les commerçants retrouvent le sourire à
marseille en a pas beaucoup
le soleil nous avons fait quelques
frayeurs et de partie civile pour le
bidon d'huile ce parti ne comptait pas
il faut vite en profiter dans cette eau
à 23 degrés car le week-end prochain les
températures vont baisser et le mistral
risque de tout emporter
à partir de demain près de 400 voitures
qui ont marqué l'histoire des 24 heures
du mans s'affronteront de nouveau sur le
célèbre circuit 50000 spectateurs
viendront rêver devant ces voitures de
collection les derniers préparatifs et
avec vincent fourcade et frédéric capron
corvette 1969 600 chevaux sous le capot
une ancienne vedette des 24 heures du
mans et 35 ans plus tard elle dévore
toujours les pistes à près de 300 km
heure ce sont des voitures réputée
solide parce qu'elles sont construites
pour rouler pendant 24 heures à une
allure très importante au pilotage jean
claude andruet 19 participations au
compteur cela fait quinze ans qu'il n'a
plus couru les 24 heures du mans
mais à peine installé au volant les
souvenirs affluent à l'époque au début
lorsque j'ai couru les 24 heures du mans
pensait que les voitures quand même
dépasser les 300 km/heure et qu'on avait
aucune sécurité il y avait même pas dry
sur le
et malheureusement moi j'ai perdu
beaucoup d'amis comme ça
les 24 heures du mans sa ligne droite
des hunaudières 80 ans de compétition
résumer en un week-end de course pour
l'occasion des voitures sans prix ont
fait le déplacement des quatre coins du
monde
des modèles qui ont écrit la légende des
24 heures et pour leurs pilotes d'un
jour c'est l'occasion unique de toucher
à la légende
quand j'étais petit j'avais un petit un
petit modèle de cette voiture alors pour
moi c'est quelque chose de formidable
je revivais des voitures modernes très
sympa mais ça c'est quelque chose
une ambiance formidable avant la course
quelques réglages à effectuer mais
demain tous seront prêts à s'élancer sur
l'un des circuits les plus célèbres au
monde dans dans un ordre un autre six as
le mans il ya les 500 miles
d'indianapolis et puis elle râle le
grand prix de monaco
et c'est incontestablement ces trois
noms qu'on va vous citez tout autour de
la planète dès qu'on parle de secours
automobile 70 marques 300 modèles
différents
dans moins de 24 heures le circuit du
mans pour un voyage dans le temps
le rendez vous de l'été à nice et bien
sûr le festival de jazz en 27 ans
d'existence ce festival s'est
progressivement ouvert à d'autres types
de musique attirant un public toujours
plus large nathalie jourdan frédéric
thierry déborder comme une tête
d'affiche qu'il est lâchés dans les
arènes de cimiez fils de la soul par le
jazz invités cormeilles un intrus
désirer
encore 7 au 17
réunir autant de couleurs différentes
sous un même sur une même étiquette de
festivals jazz se rendre hommage à ce
style là pour dire quelque part on vient
tous de la fois qu'on fasse à portée de
notes les orthodoxes andré ciccarelli et
ses amis
aujourd'hui même les purs ne sont plus
si dur
la musique jazz jazz est une musique un
peu marginal ce qui ce qui est bien est
ce que les gens aiment dans cette
musique c'est un peu dommage donc de
toute façon on est à l'ère des mélanges
mélenchon nous de façon résignés sur un
arbre perché ou sur l'herbe allonger le
public est embarrassé par le choix on
fait ici me saoule en ce moment
corneille c'est pas du tout laisse le
bon c'est sympa
quelles étaient tes musiques métissées
oui oui c'est ce qu'ont bien sur c
un molly johnson succéderont dee dee
bridgwater une enfant du jazz une vraie
mais aussi peter gabriel ou rickie lee
jones des cousins de la famille éloignée
de la famille quand même voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci à vous de
m'avoir suivi tout de suite les
prévisions météo avec nathalie relais
attention aux orages au nord de la loire
le point route julien pascal 21 55
faites entrer l'accusé présenté par
christophe hondelatte 1h05 le dernier
journal présenté par dorothée bauchard
demande dans les 4 vérités françois veut
donner recevra josé manuel barosso
nouveau président de la commission
européenne
et puis bien sûr on se quitte sur cet
hommage à sacha distel qui nous a
quittés aujourd'hui à l'âge de 75 ans
des suites d'une longue maladie
hommage bien sûr en chansons avec le
chapeau et son titre le plus populaire
scooby doo
et
je suis ayez à votre chapeau pour
apprenait qu'un quart des filles
votre soirée